الله يرحمه ايش اللي صار
يتقبله سيناريو كل ليله انه بكون في امان
الله زينا زي بقيه الناس ناس كثير تعرض
هذا سيناريو متكرر كل ليله وانتم يعني
بتغط الاحداث هذه وبتشوفوا على الساعه ا
صحين على الردم فوق روؤسنا الحمد لله ربنا
اصطفى ابن عمر عريس بقدمه لفلسطين بخطب
فلسطين بدم عمر بقدمه لربنا قبل اي شي
ربنا يتقبله هذا هذا ف هذا قطع مني انا
بقدمه لله عز وجل في سبيل الله وان شاء
الله يا رب تكون راضي يا رب ومطهره اننا
عمر مفرره هذا عريس انا قدمته للوطن
باختصار شديد جدا احنا مش متجرين لا يمكن
لا يمكن هذه ارض تتسع لاثنين ابدا مش هم
الفلسطينيين اصحاب الارض الحقيقيين حتى لو
كانت الجرح عميقه فلذت كبدي لكن فيش خيار
خيارنا الاول والثاني والمليون خيار
الصمود والتجذر في هذه الارض هذه ارضنا
ابوي غرسها ابوي سقاها وامي خرفتي روايات
حلوه كثير كثير عنها عن السوافير الشرقي
مش ح ننساها رضعته اياها وربنا اصطفاه
عندي ابن احمد حرض كلام سته وكلام سيده عن
السوافير وخليه يعشقها وخليه يعشقها باذن
الله الى ان نلقى الله وقبل هيك ان شاء
الله وع لازم يتحقق لانه فلسطين عقيده
فلسطين مش اسم فلسطين عقيده بيت المقدس
عقيده برف في دمنا في صلاتنا في تسبيحنا
في دعائنا فلسطين عقيده متمسكين فيها ليوم
الدين حتى لو بدنا نفن كل ليتنا ربنا
موجود وربنا عادل عمر انتقل من ظلم الدنيا
ظلم الاتحاد الاوروبي ظلم
بايدن حاسس فينا شايف يا بايدن شايف ايش
بتعمل انت البوارج تبعت وا طنان المتفجرات
اللي بعثتها لاسرائيل ناس مدنيين اطفال
نساء بس انت يا بايدن مش شاعر فينا مش
شاعر فينا ابدا ومش حاسس ولا انت شايف كل
حاجه بس للاسف
الشديد غيظنا الكبير من اخوتنا العرب ابني
احمد انا بطلب من الله انه يسامحنا احمد
ابني لانه انا بواسي وبقول له اولاد عمنا
اخوتنا العرب مش مطولين جايين فيريت هذه
صرخه مني احنا المساعدات زهقنا مساعدات
الاكل والشرب اخر شي بنفكر فيه فلسطين
فلسطين قاعده تذبح وابناء فلسطين
يذبحوا المساعدات اللي بيعملوا مؤتمرات
ومجلس امن عشان شويه مساعدات لا مش هذا
اللي بدها اياه فلسطين فلسطين احنا يعني
احنا انا جدت بابني بابن جدت ايش بدي انا
في المساعدات الان احنا بدنا ناس تكحل
عينينا نكحل علينا بالمسجد الاقصى اللي هو
ارضنا بدنا ناس يقفوا معنا بصراحه المجلس
الامن وكل منظمات حقوق الانسان للاسف
عاجزه يعني لمتى يعني انا ابوي عاش
التجربه هذه كله هيتها في ال 48 انه
اسرائيل مصنفه غير عن العالم وهياتي انا
برضك عشت نفس التجربه ودفعنا ثمن غالي
اسرائيل في معزل عن المسائله ليش ليش يا
بايدن مجلس الامن ليش ليش بت يعني كل مجلس
الامن متفق على قرارات معينه في اتجاه
معين انت يا بايدن ليش ليش يعني هي
الزعران الامريكيه يا سيدي نحتسب شكوانا
الى الله لمن نشكو ما ياسينا ومن يصغي
لشكوانا ويجدن الحمد لله رب العالمين ربما
هي كلمات تختصر كل الحكايه وكل القص